the differentiable functions x and y are
related by the following equation the
sine of X plus cosine of Y is equal to
square root of two they also tell us
that the derivative of X with respect to
T is equal to five they also ask us find
the derivative of Y with respect to T
when y is equal to PI over 4 and 0 is
less than X is less than PI over 2 so
given that they are telling us the
derivative of X with respect to T and we
want to find the derivative of Y with
respect to T it's a safe assumption that
both x and y are functions of T so you
could even rewrite this equation right
over here you could rewrite it as sine
of X which is a function of T plus
cosine of Y which is a function of T is
equal to square root of 2 now it might
confuse you a little bit you're not used
to seeing X as a function of a third
variable or Y is a function of something
other than X but remember x and y are
just variables this could be f of T and
this could be G of T instead of X of T
and yfd and that might feel a little bit
more natural to you but needless to say
if we want to find dy DT what we want to
do is take the derivative with respect
to T of both sides of this equation so
let's do that so we're going to do it on
the left hand side so it's going to be
retake that with respect to T derivative
of that with respect to T we're gonna
take the derivative of that with respect
to T and then we're going to take the
derivative of the right hand side this
constant with respect to T so let's
think about each of these things so what
is this let me do this in a new color
the stuff that I'm doing in this aqua
color right over here how could I write
that so I'm taking the derivative with
respect to T I have sine of something
which is itself a function of T so I
would just apply the chain rule here I'm
first going to take the derivative with
respect to X of
nine of X I could write sine of X of T
but I'll just revert back to the sine of
X here for simplicity and then I would
then multiply that times the derivative
of the inside you could say with respect
to T times the derivative of X with
respect to T this might be a little bit
counterintuitive to how you've applied
the chain rule before when we only dealt
with X's and Y's but all that's
happening I'm taking the derivative of
the outside of the sine of something
with respect to that something in this
case it is X and then I'm taking the
derivative of the something in this case
X with respect to T well we can do the
same thing here for this second term
here so I want to take the derivative
with respect to Y of I guess you could
say the outside of cosine of Y and then
I would multiply that times the
derivative of Y with respect to T and
then all of that is going to be equal to
what well the derivative with respect to
T of a constant square root of two is a
constant it's not going to change as T
changes so it's derivative it's rate of
change is zero all right so now we just
have to figure out all of these things
so first of all the derivative with
respect to X of sine of X is cosine of X
times the derivative of X with respect
to T I'll just write that out here
derivative of X with respect to T and
then we're going to have it's going to
be a plus here the derivative of Y with
respect to T so plus the derivative of Y
with respect to T I'm just swapping the
order here so that this goes out front
now what's the derivative of cosine of Y
with respect to Y well that is negative
sine of Y and so actually let me just
put the sine of Y here and then I want
to have a negative so let me erase this
and put a negative there and that is all
going to be equal to zero and so what
can we figure out now they've told us to
the derivative of X with respect to T is
equal to 5 they tell us that right over
here
so this is equal to
five we want to find the derivative of Y
with respect to T
they tell us what Y is y is PI over four
this Y is PI over four so we know this
is PI over four and let's see we have to
figure out what we still have two
unknowns here we have we don't know what
X is and we don't know what the
derivative of Y with respect to T is
this is what we need to figure out so
what would X be what would X be when y
is PI over four well to figure that out
we can go back to this original equation
right over here
so when y is PI over four you get let me
write down sine of X plus cosine of PI
over four is equal to square root of two
cosine of PI over four we revert to our
units or we think about our unit circle
we're in the first quadrant if you think
in degrees that's a 45 degree angle
that's going to be square root of two
over two and so we can subtract square
root of two over two from both sides
which is going to give us sine of X is
equal to well if you take square root of
two over two from square root of two
you're taking half of it away so you're
going to have half of it less so square
root of two over two
and so what x value when I take the sine
of it and remember where the angle if
we're thing when the unit circle is
going to be in that first quadrant X is
an angle in this case right over here
well that's going to be once again PI
over 4 so this tells us that X is equal
to PI over four when y is equal to PI
over four and so we know that this is PI
over four as well so let me just rewrite
this because it's getting a little bit
messy so we know that five times cosine
of PI over four minus dy DT the
derivative of Y with respect to T which
is what we want to figure out times sine
of PI over four is equal to zero is
equal to zero and let me put some
parentheses here just to clarify things
a little bit
all right so let's see now it's just a
little bit of algebra cosine of PI over
four we already know is square root of 2
over 2 sine of PI over 4 is also square
root of 2 over 2 now let's see what if
we divide both sides of this equation by
square root of 2 over 2
well what's that going to give us well
then this square root of 2 over 2
divided by square root of 2 over square
root of 2 over 2 divided by square root
of 2 over 2 is going to be 1 square root
of 2 over 2 divided by square root of 2
over 2 is going to be 1 and then 0
divided by square root of 2 over 2 is
just still going to be 0 and so this
whole thing simplifies to 5 times 1
which is just 5 minus the derivative of
Y with respect to T is equal to 0 and so
there you have it you add the derivative
of Y with respect to T to both sides and
we get the derivative of Y with respect
to T is equal to 5 when all of these
other things are true when the
derivative of X with respect to T is 5
and the derivative and why I should say
is equal to PI over 4